With America's 250th birthday
right around the corner, the
fight over what it means to be a
patriot, well, it feels more
intense than ever.
But what if the fight ends not
with a clear winner, but with
one side kind of accidentally
convincing itself the other was
right all along?
We're going to dive into a
fascinating theory today about
how exactly that could happen.
So the story kicks off with this
pretty wild premise.
You've got a political group
that sees patriotism as this
super powerful brand, right?
And they decide, hey, let's just
adopt its symbols for purely
strategic reasons.
It's basically like putting on a
costume, you know, just to win
over an audience.
And that right there, that leads
us to the big question we're
tackling today.
What happens when that
performance stops being just an
act?
What if the costume, that thing
you just put on starts to feel
like your own skin?
And believe me, this is where
the story gets really
interesting.
So why did this performance even
begin?
Well, to understand that, we've
got to look at the upcoming get
this semi Quincentennial.
Yeah, that's a mouthful.
I know.
It's the official name for
America's 250th birthday.
And according to the theory
we're exploring, this big party
on the horizon created an
absolute full blown political
panic.
OK, So what was the fear?
The fear was that this
anniversary would turn into a
massive, years long political
rally just for one side of the
aisle.
So you have the progressive
establishment, and they're
really worried about losing
their grip on the national
story.
They feel like they have to do
something and something drastic
to stop the American flag from
basically becoming the exclusive
property of just one group.
So a plan was hatched.
The source we're pulling from
calls it the Great Patriotic
Heist.
It's this deliberate strategy to
go out and reclaim the symbols
of American patriotism.
And this is key.
It wasn't about some new found
genuine belief.
No, this was pure brand
management.
Let's be super clear about what
this heist actually is.
The idea is that you can perform
love of country, you know, wave
the flags, say all the right
words, but not because you
actually feel it.
You're doing it to take away its
power as a political weapon for
your opponents to neutralize it.
And this is basically the
playbook.
First up, reclaimed the whole
look and feel of patriotism.
Next, you reframe the very act
of descent as the highest form
of patriotism.
See what they did there.
And then you take all these
progressive ideas and you just
wrap them up in red, white and
blue.
And at the same time, you shift
the focus away from 1776 and on
to this idea of America as a
project that's always
unfinished.
But, you know, here's the twist,
and it's a big one.
The thing about any performance
is that the actors can start to
believe their own lines.
And that's exactly what
supposedly happens here.
This strategic gesture, this
thing that was only meant to be
temporary, it starts to have
this real, totally unintended
effect on the people doing the
performing.
The philosopher Jean Paul Sartre
really put it best.
You become what you pretend to
be.
The source we're looking at
argues this is almost like a
kind of American magic.
You start by performing an
ideal, right, like patriotism,
and just by going through the
motions, you slowly, almost
accidentally, start to make it
real for yourself.
The theory uses this really
powerful metaphor for this whole
journey, a cultural rumspringa.
Now, if you know the term, it's
from the Amish tradition.
It's when young people leave
their closed community to go
experience the real world.
And in this context, it's
describing progressive stepping
out of their own cultural bubble
to actually engage with, you
know, mainstream America.
So the journey looks something
like this.
First you leave that bubble of
constant critique, you step
outside.
You're expecting to find, well,
basically barbarism, right?
A shallow, hostile culture.
But instead, and this is the
shock, you discover kindness,
you find community, a real sense
of belonging.
And after that, there's just no
way you can go back completely
unchanged.
So what is it that's actually
causing this big change?
Well, this brings us to the
secret main character of our
whole story, this unseen, quiet
force that actually holds all
the power.
It's called the default
Republic.
And the key thing to get here is
that this is not a political
party.
It's a temperament.
We're talking about the huge
majority of people, maybe 80%,
who aren't online arguing about
culture all day.
They're not writing manifestos.
They're just living their lives.
And by doing that, they act as
the country's stabilizing force.
They're the ballast in the ship.
And it's secret power isn't
aggression, it's absorption.
The theory calls this cultural
judo.
Think about it.
It doesn't fight its critics
head on.
Instead, it uses their own
energy, their own momentum to
just pull them into the
mainstream.
It basically metabolizes
rebellion until it just becomes
another part of the system.
And you know, this isn't some
new thing.
If you look back to American
history, patriotism has gone
through constant reboots.
I mean, it started as an act of
rebellion.
Then it became about civic duty.
Then you had this split between
patriotism as branding versus
patriotism as protest.
Then it became kitschy and about
recovery.
And more recently, it's been
framed through trauma and
disillusionment.
The point is, the definition is
always changing because the
country is always absorbing new
arguments and ideas and fitting
them under that same flag.
So how does this all end?
How does this story resolve?
Well, it's not with a big epic
battle.
It's within invitation.
The final act isn't one side
crushing the other, it's one
side simply quietly welcoming
the other one home.
And the source gives us this
just fantastic metaphor to
explain this.
On one hand, you have the
bonfire.
This is the ideological
approach.
It's where everyone gathers to
shout their theories and burn
down old myths.
It's all about control.
But then you have the barbecue,
and that's the default Republic.
It's messy, it's loud, it's
communal.
You're not shouting theories,
you're sharing plates.
It's not about control at all.
It's about belonging.
And here's the really crucial
point.
The greatest strength of this
quiet majority is just
hospitality.
It doesn't punish the performers
for their initial hypocrisy.
It doesn't shout, I told you so.
It sees them coming back not as
a surrender, but just as them
growing up.
It forgives them for coming home
late and simply hands them a
plate.
And this next quote, man, it
just captures the entire theory
in one perfect sentence.
It says it all.
The default Republic doesn't
argue with the revolution.
It feeds it dinner.
That's it.
That's the whole game.
And so all of this leaves us
with one final big question to
think about.
Is the future of patriotism
really an argument that has to
be won?
Or is it more like a BBQ that
you can just join?
Maybe it's not some fortress
that has to be captured, but
just an open invitation to a
party that's been going on this
whole time.